we're finally going to learn what kind
of game Suicide Squad killed the Justice
League is going to be and we're going to
land that information at a PlayStation
state of play of all places announced
for Thursday February 23rd Sony promises
the highlight of its Nintendo
direct-esque presentation will be 15
minutes of Suicide Squad gameplay and
details despite Rocksteady announcing
the game in August 2020 and having shown
off gameplay already the developer has
been tight-lipped regarding its actual
mechanics one thing players know is that
the game will feature Co-op which after
the failed Avengers game and Ill
received loot grind multiplayer aspects
of DC Zone Gotham Knights as fans
worried that what should be an excellent
game will be marred by live service
miasma these fears were seemingly
Justified earlier this year when a leak
from the game seemed to reveal the
game's live service elements including a
battle pass system for character
Cosmetics which was exactly how Marvel's
Avengers operated a game based around
the most popular pop culture franchise
that will shut down later this year
ahead of its three-year anniversary
hopefully Thursday's state of play will
clarify what players can actually expect
from this game and assuage their
concerns on top of Suicide Squad details
the state of play will have updates on
other third-party titles as well as
reveal five more upcoming psvr 2 games
the device going on sale the day prior
sounds like you shouldn't expect any
news on non-vr first party games such as
Insomniac Spider-Man 2 scheduled for
release this fall please let one of
those VR2 titles be Half-Life Alex
speaking of psvr 2 ahead of the device's
launch on Wednesday PlayStation unveiled
10 more games joining its launch lineup
rounding out the total number of titles
available to users on day one to 40.
these titles include another Fisherman's
tale a sequel to the award-winning
puzzle VR game a fisherman's tale knock
bow and arosaka a multiplayer experience
where you play soccer with a bow and
arrow and unplugged egg a Guitar Hero
like game without the plastic
peripherals a full list of the new
additions can be found at gamespot.com
new additions are also coming to Xbox
game pass which will be sneaking in a
few more games before the end of the
month these include merge and blade a
fantasy puzzle Auto battler and the
supernatural cyberpunk jrpg Soul hackers
too both of which land on February 22nd
then in early March right before warlong
Fallen Dynasty drops on the third racing
game F1 2022 will be joining the
rosteria EA play full details on
everything coming and going from Xbox
game pass can also be found at
gamespot.com PlayStation isn't the only
one putting out a presentation next week
on Monday February 27th the 27th
anniversary of the original Pocket
Monsters red and green releasing in
Japan there will be a 20 minute Pokemon
presents showcase last year's Pokemon
Day presentation saw the announcement of
last Falls Pokemon scarlet and violet
and while Nintendo probably isn't ready
to reveal a gen 10 of the franchise
speculation is that more let's go games
likely remakes of gold and silver will
be announced particularly as this year
will be the five-year anniversary of the
first installments releasing I don't
know what's more unbelievable that it's
been 27 years since Pokemon first
launched or that it's been five years
since Pokemon let's go Pikachu and Eevee
what is your excitement level for
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
what are you hoping to see from next
week's Pokemon presents let us know in
the comments we'll see you here for more
Gamespot news
[Music]